[Music]  i met a guy and i haven't heard from him  and it sucks  that is not how we work through our  issues  jen  you're a superhero  i don't want to be a hulk  but there are upsides your ass looks  crazy right now  this is the best that i've had in a  while  oh  she-hulk attorney at law original series  streaming august 18th only on disney  floss whether you like it or not  you're now a superhero  very good she's trying to show you no  i'm done i'm shown i did not go to law  school to become a vigilante  our universe is on the edge of a  precipice all right let's do this  who the hell are you  that name better not stick  attorney at law only on disney plus  because being a superhero is a trial by  fire  bruce i'm not gonna be a superhero what  else you're gonna do as a hulk  we just started a superhuman law  division and i want the she-hulk to be  the face-off  we do things by the book the book of the  shanty the book of american  uh lost  [Music]  you